[Music]
good morning welcome to Google cloud
next 2018 I hope you all had a chance to
enjoy the keynote just prior to this and
are excited to get started for a week of
learning about cloud and what Google is
doing in this market today we're here to
talk about managing your costs in GCP
this is IO 118 and we're looking at
managing your costs and how to best
structure your GCP resources to make
cost reporting simple so we're here to
answer one key question that question is
what is the best way to structure your
resources in order to understand and
manage cost now we're going to go
through this in seven sections a brief
introduction a look at the fundamentals
and foundations of billing on cloud will
talk about organizations specifically
GCP organizations will talk about
folders labels a few advanced topics and
then we will attempt to leave a lot of
time for your questions there are two
mics you're welcome to come up ask the
questions you have about billing and if
we run out of time there are lots of
billing product managers and engineers
here who are happy to help today or at
another time so a quick introduction Who
am I I'm James I'm a product manager in
Google cloud and I work on billing and
billing is a challenge in an environment
like cloud a lot of services bill by the
second a lot of services bill at
extremely high rates we have dozens and
dozens and dozens of services reporting
back onto your bill and our mission is
to make billing trustworthy transparent
simple and predictable and we're working
with a great engineering team to do that
every day
and we're always trying to provide you
capabilities and features and new
services at customer friendly prices and
billing has a big part to play in that
so today you'll look at how to use
projects organizations folders as your
primary ways of structuring GCP
resources we will also look at labels
which are a way to cross cut across
those boundaries to do more advanced
reporting and we'll introduce billing
exports and billing reports to dive into
that billing data now there are a few
other sessions later in the week at next
and I'll call those out as they're great
ways to go deeper into how to handle
billing reporting and other billing
needs and so the way we'll structure
today is we'll take a journey together
we will start as a solo developer I'm
told that all solo developers have a dog
and work in a garage we'll start there
and move all the way across to being a
large multinational corporation with
thousands of developers working across
dozens of projects and services in cloud
now first let's ask where you are in
your journey just to get a quick show of
hands how many solo developers do we
have there's one at least one I don't
see any dogs in the room that may be a
policy apologies next time we'll try
unless you bring your dog how many CIOs
are CTOs of multinational companies
anyone got at least one - I'm kidding a
little bit we know that most of our
audience sit in between those two
extremes so now a real show of hands how
many of you used GCP today amazing
pretty much everyone in the room how
many of you have an organization a GCP
organization most of the people in the
room how many of you use folders now
we're down to maybe 20% of the room how
many of you use labels I thought I saw a
lot of those folder hands stay up for
labels that's good
finally the bonus question how many of
you export your billing data using the
bigquery export
good turnout thank you very much that is
going to be a theme throughout today's
journey I'm going to try and convince
everyone here to export your data to the
bigquery billing export because it's
amazing so we're at different stages in
our journey and we're gonna start small
go all the way across to big and
hopefully along the way you'll see
yourselves in the structures we're
looking at and see tips you can take
home take to your teams and use in your
journey on cloud along the way you will
see eight green slides like this one
they are tips and tricks and best
practices and takeaways that you should
think about for any use of cloud and
we'll recap them at the end and of
course these slides this presentation
will be publicly available so no need to
take furious notes you can always come
back later and see what we've talked
about today so the fundamentals of
billing on cloud let's start with
projects projects are the core
organizing entity in cloud when you have
a service such as compute engine or
kubernetes or cloud sequel or storage
you'll see them creating resources in
the context of projects now projects are
containers for resources and also
describe the settings and permissions
and other metadata around your workloads
a separate concept in cloud is that of
the billing account and a billing
account defines who pays for projects
and resources now a project is always
paid for by a single billing account and
billing accounts actually have their own
separate roles and permissions from
projects in the hierarchy a billing
account operates in one currency and it
can be funded by a credit card a debit
card
other payment instruments depending on
jurisdiction or it can be funded by an
invoice now billing accounts are always
funded on a monthly basis now it's easy
in fact it's incredibly easy to move
projects between billing accounts you
can do it yourself and you can
self-serve that process using the
billing section of cloud one request if
we could reload the presentation I've
noticed we're on an older version so if
you could just hit reload in the middle
on the same screen I'm sure it'll come
up with latest so in addition to
projects we have both organizations and
folders which are ways of containing and
grouping projects the best way to think
of these structures is that they mirror
your organization that's why we named
organizations organizations and folders
can be nested and you can think of them
as the primary key in a sense to your
projects our project can only live and
be owned by one folder organizations can
also contain billing accounts allowing
for the central management of billing
roles and permissions but they're
independent from projects they have
separate roles separate permissions
finally at the most granular level we
have labels labels are ad-hoc key value
pairs assigned to resources
it is we just have to hit reload on it
and we'll be all set alright thanks
we'll pick it back up with labels labels
associate resources across projects and
are the cross-cutting ways of doing
reporting that you can't model with
nested folders so a number of examples
here what team is working on a
particular resource is it a database is
it in production is it in Mountain View
is it active is it pending you can apply
those key value pairs across resources
and additionally they may have other
powers on a per service basis but for
billing they're a tremendously powerful
way to crosscut reporting and critically
they appear in your big query billing
export a topic you will hear me keep
hammering on until I've convinced every
single one of you that it's a wonderful
thing to do a cost management is how we
report and allow you to control those
costs across all of your projects
folders and within your organization now
I'm going to draw a distinction here
between your invoice which tells you how
much and cost management which tells you
why and where costs were raised and
we'll look at a moment at how those
differ cost management lets you slice
and dice cost particularly by project
but also by label and overtime folder
and the major areas are cost reporting
budgets and alerting to let you know
when you've hit certain thresholds of
cost and our famed export there are four
other sessions with a lot more detail
that you may like to attend later on
monitoring and forecasting saving money
on compute engine a topic worthy of its
own discussion a deep dive into
exporting data and cutting and slicing
it with data studio and a financial
governance session about controlling
cost now first first big green tip of
course you already knew what it would be
and
come back to it later on it's turn on
the bigquery building export now this
export exports extremely fine-grained
data about your usage of cloud but even
at high volume it's unlikely to cost you
very much to turn on this export your
free cap includes some storage that will
likely cover your use of this export but
we let you turn it on so you have
control of both access to it and what
project it it sits in and you can turn
it on in the billing section under
billing export choose a project that it
resides in and choose a data set to host
it in so that's tip number one so let's
get started with our hello world example
we have one billing account one project
and five services that were funding so a
billing account pays for a project
project owns resources and let's flip
our colors so we have a little
color-coded key for the rest of this
discussion and note that the pay is for
is the dotted green line and owns as the
blue line billing counts don't own
projects they just fund them and that's
an important distinction as we go
through our discussion of ownership so
we've just started our new company one
billing account one production project
things are great users are pouring in
we've got all our resources under the
hood there I've hidden them so that it's
a little bit easier to read these slides
but under that project are all of the
resources in GCP things are going great
we've hired two developers Alice and Bob
Alice and Bob are off to the races
they're staying up late they're working
hard to get a set next set of users
unfortunately Bob is not the world's
greatest Linux hacker doesn't realize
that RM dash RF works quickly and
efficiently to destroy your files alice
is really fast typist but every now and
then she forgets a where clause in her
sequel statements now I'll do my own
show of hands in my time before Google I
have done both of these things on large
production systems I ran an uncapped
where clause on a hundred million row
table
that couple million rows in I have
deleted the root filesystem of a
production linux host it's always the
pause that gets you you sit and you
think why is this taking so low
another tip along the way you can change
the radius of the smile in the faces on
Google slides so I highly recommend you
explore those advanced features so from
hello world to hello
development environment why on earth
would we run everything in one project
give everyone permission to it of course
it's best practice to carve out
environments to isolate environments by
stage and by who's using them so we
forgive Alice and Bob we have a
blameless postmortem
we should have offered better
protections they're still happy they're
still working away not running terrible
removes and updates in production now
how will you see this cost well we'll
talk about that in a moment but this
brings our second tip one that I think
will resonate well with users of GCP use
projects to isolate and enforce
boundaries between resources and use
them as containers for policy so they
enforce I am permissions access and
management permissions of who can access
resources and other policies to dictate
what happens in a in a particular subset
of your resources on GCP so you should
create projects freely lots of customers
in GCP start with one project go all the
way up to thousands you can think of
them as almost a free construct so how
do these charges appear well you'll get
a bill something like this every month
an invoice and it tells you of course
how much is due up at the top it also
tells you on a per project basis the
usage of each service now a couple of
notes on this invoice first the invoice
is always at the project level it is not
going to cut down and slice up your cost
into finer buckets second is that once
you hit 25 pages this beautiful PDF
turns back into a one-page PDF and says
the number you owe some of our customers
would have literally thousands and
thousands of pages of invoice and yeah
there's only so much we're gonna
generate into PDF form but behind every
PDF is also a CSV that shows this level
of detail as for as many rows of data as
you have cost reporting is the second
way you can surface this cost data and
there's a session that goes much deeper
into this but cost reporting is the
place to slice and dice usage by time by
project by product by SKU you can slice
and dice just about any way you can
imagine and we're investing a lot of
resource into making this a fast
first-class way of understanding what's
happening in GCP we'll come to a tip in
a moment but this is the place to look
for why cost is happening and from where
now if you want to go a level deeper
let's get into that bigquery export what
do you get you get incredibly
fine-grained usage down to the SKU and
label level of everything that's
happening across your projects and we'll
talk when we look at the label features
of labels about how you can actually use
this to query your data and of course
there's a separate section that goes
deep into it but the bigquery export is
a fantastic tool for understanding every
nuance of cost critically when you turn
on your bigquery export and have a
question down the road you can grant
access to your export to cloud billing
support we have a dedicated team a
support team that can help you answer
gnarly questions and they can do it
alongside you and data that's available
to both you and them so our tip around
cost reporting and invoicing the invoice
tells you what you owe cost reporting
tells you why and where and I think it's
important to keep we believe it's
important to keep those two concepts
separate so we've isolated our resources
into projects as the basic organizing
entity in GCP we've looked at some of
the cost management tools and ways that
cost is surfaced across the platform and
the use cases are of course much more
broad than what I described here with
the production environment the
development environment you can cut your
projects any way you like depending on
how you structure your resources and
we'll look at some more ways in a moment
so our company is growing like
gangbusters we have projects galore we
have added a staging environment in the
middle also a great idea we have an old
macro service I made that up it's not a
micro service it's a monolith that we
forklift into a project we have a
top-secret project we're not sure what
the new business development team is
doing but they're doing something in
there very locked down very secret don't
mention it and an archive project where
we put old storage data in in cloud
storage now you can imagine as you go
from 1 to 2 to 6 to 10 projects to a
hundred that at some point this becomes
a little bit painful you might want to
control who has access to these at the
highest level who is a member of your
organization what policies do you want
to flow down across all these projects
you might want to have detailed audit
logs everything that's happening inside
this organization and so we add a
centralization above projects called a
GCP organization and many of you I think
almost half the room raise their hand
when we asked how many of you had a GCP
organization now I'm going to get rid of
those dotted green lines because
something we're working on hard today is
to add the concept of a default billing
account at the organization level so in
the future you won't have to think about
associating each project to a separate
billing account so going forward I'm
just going to leave that one little
dotted green line and one little blue
line to say that this organization owns
all of the projects below it and the
billing account pays for all the
projects below
now historically a GCP organization
required you to have a Google G suite
apps account it no longer does you can
use a free cloud identity account
associate that to your to your projects
and in cloud and use organizations for
free without having to use G suite so
organizations are available to everyone
and they're a fantastic way to control
users policies permissions at the top
level and it's really easy to move
projects into an organization you can
also move billing accounts into an
organization yourself so we've gotten to
about ten projects and already I think
you can see that groupings of these
projects are starting to divide
themselves we have on the left our
development environments production
staging we have in the middle our macro
service it has some environments as well
we've acquired two companies apparently
things are really moving top-secret is
still hiding on the side along with
archive folders let you group projects
together folders can be nested and they
also let you apply in a more narrow way
those policies and settings that you
previously applied at the organization
level and they are a fantastic way to
start thinking about something like a
primary key for how you organize billing
data now a project can only belong to
one folder but of course it can belong
to a nested set of folders so you have
to think a little bit ahead of how your
folder structure might represent your
resources in your organization here
we'll chop it up one way which is to
make an app section for our main
application put the macro service and a
macro services and their environments in
a folder give biz biz dev their acquired
companies and leave top-secret and
archive off to the side and of course
you can go much further than this you
might choose to cut by Department if
Finance wants to keep an area for
invoicing and a storage area for
vendors they may do that in a separate
folder of course you can nest folders
sales has just gone and nested their
folders by region so folders mirror how
you work and you'll see them start to
percolate throughout our cost management
tooling and throughout our billing
infrastructure to give you that view of
groups of projects now let's get to the
most I think powerful and interesting
feature of how to control cost and that
is the label so you're living in this
world you're a CFO and you say wow we
have a lot of resources in GCP I heard
from a developer the other day I was
having lunch with them and they said
that we're spending 50% of our GCP
dollars on databases and I said really
don't I don't see database up there
anywhere how do I know what that cost is
across everything that I operate so
let's take just a slice of this world
we're gonna take the app section and cut
away the West and the rest for
simplicity and let's show what's under
the hood
we've brought services back we have GCE
we have cloud storage we have bigquery
we have cloud sequel and well we have a
bare-metal database running on a bunch
of VMs inside our GCE bucket here of
resources so we can apply a label to
those resources
now labels expose themselves in
different ways from service to service
and their function is not only for
purposes of billing labels are used for
other reasons such as in GCE you can
filter and sort and manage VMs by label
and we've tagged our bare metal
databases here with the type database
and of course cloud sequel want to tag
those as databases as well but haha
we realized that we only really run
databases a bigquery database in
production we don't have that in the
other environment
and we back up a whole huge pile of
database data into cloud storage so
let's label that bucket database as well
because it follows the same cost model
now we have a cross-cutting
view of usage that spans all of those
folders and projects and goes across our
entire organization now there are
trade-offs between folders and labels
and as I mentioned one way to think
about folders is there kind of a primary
key a primary index across your projects
and projects can only have one parent
folder but resources and projects can
have many many labels as I showed before
it's common for customers to have dozens
of labels on complex resources that tell
them all about the environment location
customer type and other metadata about
their resources
now our guidance here is be deliberate
now you have to be especially deliberate
when you're constructing folders because
you have to build a hierarchy but with
labels it's a good idea to be deliberate
as well define the keys that you that
are mandatory across services define
what valid values are and set a policy
around which kinds of services require
labeling and which don't and as I
mentioned some services use labels for
other functions some services also apply
their own labels to resources for your
benefit when you're looking at big query
export in other places so you'll get
cluster IDs deployment manager will
append IDs on to its resources and
you'll see those percolate all the way
throughout cost reporting and throughout
bigquery now how does this actually look
here is a slice of a bigquery export if
you had a pool of VMs that are reporting
cost through to bigquery we are going to
cut those up by labelled usage so you'll
get a line item for each combination of
labels and the associated
cost and one of the great powers of
bigquery is its ability to query into
nested data structures so we provide you
example queries and example ways of
surfacing these labels in our bigquery
export documentation that tell you and
let you pivot on those those values to
do a real fine cost attribution so use
labels for cross-cutting reporting that
span all of your projects and they're
powerful we have customers who use them
as their primary means of managing costs
and don't use folders as heavily it
depends on your workload that depends
how you how flexibly you want to see the
world of cost I will caution you on one
note which is that most of our labels
are evaluated at the time that bigquery
export runs so if you're applying labels
in a really high frequency way to
underlying resources your export may not
exactly match those in in perfect
real-time so when I say high frequency I
mean if you're putting labels on and off
resources at a inter hour or a really
fine rate much faster than our bigquery
export which is a few hours delayed you
may see the last value of that label so
it's worth experimenting with and if you
have needs that require real
fine-grained labeling at in real time
come talk to us reach out to our the
building product management or
engineering teams and we'll be happy to
talk to you about those cases now a few
advanced topics and I think we'll have
about 10 minutes for questions after we
get through advanced topics and our
summary and we'll have two microphones
ready for you for any questions you have
so please start start thinking of them
in your mind first billing roles and
permissions billing permissions are
separate from resource permissions what
I mean by that is you have a series of
roles that you can centrally control if
you have an organization on the billing
accounts in that organization some of
those common roles are the billing
administrator role who has the rights to
do everything a billing account creator
who can
other billing accounts and a billing
account viewer who can look at cost and
reporting but who cannot change the
settings change the way payments are
processed change how your your finances
are run now once your organization is
established your GCP organization is
established there are a couple of best
practices around billing account
permissions that we want you to take
home with you
the first is after you've created your
org if you're in a pre-existing GCP
customer move your billing accounts into
the org it doesn't happen for you
automatically there's a big button on
top of the billing account that says to
choose the organization it's associated
to so you can move them in-game that
gain that same level of control you have
after you've moved all of your projects
into the organization which is the
second tip the third is once you have
your billing structure set up you can
remove the billing account creator role
that exists as a default at the top
level of the organization it's there to
allow the easy adoption of organizations
but once you've got your structure
nailed down you may well want to take it
away a couple of best practices on
billing account hygiene all things equal
we generally think that fewer billing
accounts are preferable to many unless
you have specific reasons for having
lots of billing accounts costs always
flow up to a single billing account and
you can think of that billing account as
the top-level container for cost
reporting so it's if you have usage
spread across billing accounts you may
have to construct reports in less easy
ways to see costs between those billing
accounts some of the reasons you may
want or need multiple billing accounts
if you have divisions of a large
corporation they may want their own
control of costs they may operate in
their own currency as I mentioned before
a billing account operates in a single
currency and there may be other reasons
that you want to split charges or split
invoicing in a way that follow a
different path
above all if you're if you're thinking
you're going down that route talk to
your account manager or I'm happy to
answer questions after but generally
speaking fewer is better finally you may
have a use case for chargebacks
internally inside your organization
where you have one billing account but
where you're allocating cost in a more
discreet manner inside your company and
there are different ways to cut charge
backs you can do it by folder you can do
it by label you can do it by project
we'd love to help with that problem
so by all means please reach out and
talk to us and we're happy to give you
some idea of best practice and give you
an idea of what other customers have
done before you with our reporting tools
finally a note I mentioned it earlier
there is a dedicated cloud billing
support team whether you pay for Google
cloud support or not this team is always
available to you to answer questions and
in the support section there's a clear
link that says where to reach out to the
cloud billing support team and as I've
hammered home they will be extra excited
if you turned on your bigquery billing
export because they'd love to get down
in and help you with some of those cost
attribution questions at the final up
line level of detail so a quick summary
some ways to learn more and then about
10 minutes for questions first you've
already heard me say that enough turn it
on projects are a great way to enforce
boundaries and you can create them
freely use projects for any use case you
see fit
prefer cost reporting to relying on the
invoice for details about cost the
invoice is a great tool for that quick
summary but cost reporting lets you get
down to slicing and dicing cost in all
of the ways we've talked about GCP orgs
are for everyone they're a fantastic way
to control resources if you don't
already have one and you can set them up
either using cloud ID ass
or using your G Suite applications
domain folders which you can nest up to
four levels deep are a great way to
mirror the structure of how you work
whether it's by team by department by
project with how your resources sit in
Google Cloud and you can think of them
something like the primary key or the
primary way to index your projects and
finally labels are a way to supercharge
reporting and cut across the boundaries
of projects create as many as you like
use them for those cases where you need
to slice and dice in ways that folders
can't do or folders can't do alone and
as I said cloud billing support is here
to help we've heard from lots of
customers we talked customers every day
about the different problems they're
aiming to solve with billing and we're
thrilled to help and find solutions any
time as I mentioned there are four more
sessions IO 103 monitoring and
forecasting your DCP costs on Thursday
at 11:40 a.m. IO 128 saving money on
compute engine talking about committed
and sustained use discounts io 208 on
Wednesday which dives into billing data
with bigquery and data studio bigquery
is something you can query ad hoc in the
style of sequel or you can use data
studio and our other reporting tools on
top to give you visualizations and
really rich custom cost reporting and
finally controlling costs with financial
governance which is at 315 today there's
also a cost management showcase where
you can see if you can handle Black
Friday I encourage you to check that out
I believe it's downstairs
[Music]